hey guys so I'm off to dinner with
Francesca and Diana it's our annual
girls Christmas holiday celebration I
just wrapped that presents last minute
I'm actually already late for dinner as
usual but I think I did a really a
really mediocre job I got them these
candy land candy things it's actually
candy inside the candy land box so I'm
pretty pumped about that yeah so after
that we're gonna be going to a show my
friends band is called Lakes you should
check them out if you have not heard
them they're amazing and we're gonna go
to hotel cafe so let's go like look out
look at Diana just the freakin Santa
Claus over here like wrapping things all
nicely it's very same thing I threw this
all in a bag before we came here and get
this so you guys remember the video like
two days ago at the Apple Store where we
saw that kid Jordan who showed us the
xoxo fabric that you can stick it on the
wall of the Apple store guess what done
you're gonna go I mean like this is how
crazy is this
everyone's gonna be like Justin you're
definitely sponsored I am NOT sponsored
it's just it just so happens Emily fun
so we already ate dinner it was fabulous
but most importantly there are dessert
minute like a maple apple cider same
thing
like hang I know I'm gonna end my blog
so we instantly are like okay put the
hair in front okay we're sad we're set
we're sad so we just met this girl she
does the most amazing nail art like you
have to go follow her Instagram right
now nail nail Jameel nai l lost my mind
like it was really good
oh my god because really she does
paintings on the nail barely good so she
did a like a Rembrandt
mattiece painters okay she made a really
cool doll she's a really cool french
bulldog she did like pixelated mushrooms
and super from Super Mario agro yeah I
definitely it was I was speechless when
I was looking at this Instagram it was
like well I know what I have got a plan
for next year annual oh that's right
we're Google glass like an idiot look we
could have snuck through here we could
have see yep yep why trouble all right
well this is yes video is not over okay
get in the light can I have my heels on
it makes me feel like I have to show
them all because I rarely you guys know
me they look I mean let's turn the side
oh that's nice shimmer really shiny
guys we don't get out much oh look it's
12:00 midnight
oh wow I bet it's past your bedtime I
know son de Noirs monday every time I
see you guys are like when we're working
and that's like a fun times it's our
first time going down on drinks yeah
hole to hole two we have parts
dinner and travel we had a little pretty
long dinner it was great kids don't once
for basically I was amazing all right
guys we'll see you tomorrow